no I'm not gonna sing to myself so yeah
birthday video time and this is gonna be
the Q&A and I'm also shooting this other
thing that I may or may not integrate
into it depending on how long the Q&A
ends up BTW being why am I even shooting
it I don't know it's on a whim okay I
went to the PIO box today grabbed what
may or may not be the last batch of
stuff that I'm that I'm receiving from
you folks and yeah I haven't opened any
of it yet and so yeah this heavens Leon
I'm not gonna mention last names just
because I don't know how much privacy
people wanted to have probably got
around a lot oh boy that would be a fez
god how should i okay so I've got I've
got the Q&A questions up now I will say
that I I you know made no promises about
answering all of them so I have narrowed
these down the only people who had
guaranteed answers were my patreon
supporters they were guaranteed to get
an answer to their questions the ones
that that I got otherwise I've gone
through them some of them I took out
some of them because they are things
that I've answered in other places some
of them I took out because I honestly
didn't have an interesting answer and
even in the case of some of them were
interesting questions I just didn't have
a good answer for them and and you know
I trimmed others down you know similar
questions and and various reasons so if
I didn't pick your question it is
nothing personal and part of it is just
trying to fit this into a single video
but god I preamble too much these days
so here we go I decided to put this one
at the top which
is your name and preferred pronouns so
my name is Nathaniel on the on my
published works it's Vera because those
are those are written under very while
which is the name of my other channel
pronouns I mean generally masculine
tends to make more sense on this
particular channel but what I tell
people is just whatever makes the most
sense in your head when you think of me
whatever pronoun like clicks in your
brain go with that I won't care if you
could take over Doctor Who as showrunner
what directions or changes would you
make and why what would your version of
the show be like disregarding things
like butter budget etc I actually don't
know at this point because the thing is
truth be told
a lot of the things that I would want to
do series 11 actually did with you know
things like no Daleks for for a for a
series mostly self-contained stories no
mystery box series arc those were a lot
of the things I would have done which I
suppose given my films on series 11 just
goes to show that you know it's always
execution dependent so at this point I
don't know what I would do because most
things I would I would want to do the
latest series did and have as made me as
left me if nothing else go okay even if
I came in and like did that better than
they did I still feel like we need to we
need to step off and do something else
so I don't have a big idea there what do
you think of the Doctor Who spin-off
shows Torchwood Sarah Jane Adventures in
class which one's your favorite well
first of all I've actually I still
haven't seen class I haven't gotten
around to it I guess I guess it's
Torchwood Torchwood is super uneven but
children of earth is great
whereas Sarah Jane Adventures is pretty
good but is pitched at a much younger
age you know then I you know I I suspect
if I had been if I had been younger when
it aired I probably would have loved it
but given the age that I was when it
airs I'm I think it's fine but you know
it's not for me if you could invite five
people dead alive real or fictional to
dinner who would you invite and why so I
did end up going with
all real people some living some dead I
have a nice nin Douglas Adams Eddie
Izzard Lyndsey Ellis Neil Gaiman because
I think it would make for an evenings
conversation that would be entertaining
humorous philosophical just a little bit
naughty so moving along from there uh
what kind of music do you like this one
I actually got asked several times any
comes up in the the livestreams law I
don't have like genres that I'm like ooh
what's the latest thing going on here
like I have a couple of artists that I
that I have been following for a long
time people like Weird Al
pink Lindsey Stirling miracle sound for
a while now Queen I quite like but like
it's not when I go to Spotify what any
time I try and like go oh I'll check out
this genre today I end up getting bored
with it pretty quick so my tastes are
really kind of all over the all over the
place with music they're not
consistently one style of music there
are a couple of things that I'm not big
on I'm not huge on on hip hop not big on
country and again not that I think that
they're bad they're just again just not
for me
what are some of your favorite movies or
TV shows that you think to lgbtq+
representation the right way I actually
don't really have an answer to this one
but it's similar to several other
questions that were asked the thing is
is that I fir for someone who cares as
much about representation as I have
there are very significant portions of
lgbtq+ representation entertainment that
I have not taken in because I would have
no interest in them if it wasn't for the
presence of lgbtq+ thing what I mean by
that is most movies TV shows etc that
deal in that tend to either be dramas or
romances which are two of the general
genres I care the least about I like
lasers and superpowers and and you know
aliens and fantastical beings and you
just don't see lgbtq+ people and those
as much so I'm actually a really bad
resource for you know what what is the
good stuff I don't really know because
the kind of entertainment I like so
rarely includes lgbtq+ people and if it
does they're pretty much always
background or side characters so like
I'm just not a great resource for as
much as I like to analyze and pick apart
and certainly we'll take issue with
trends trying to trying to ask me you
know well where's the good stuff the
good stuffs in genres that I don't enjoy
which is really frustrating for me one
of the TV shows you watched it as a kid
at various ages like say when you were
five ten fifteen so when I was five
it would have been things like he-man
Thundercats the Real Ghostbusters was a
big one
also my Graham my grandparents had the
Disney Channel so just Disney cartoons
ten actually ten I was was really just
kind of digging into video games at that
point because I would have my Super
Nintendo which was really my gaming
heyday at that point um 15 I was I was
getting into The Simpsons the thing is
though I know I've never had live TV
coming into my home when I was growing
up um you know and even though even the
cartoons that I liked they were things
that my grandmother taped for me off of
her cable and I had you know these VHS
is that she made for me so like I was
out of the loop and not and I didn't
have the ability just browse around and
see what there was have you ever had
jelly babies so far no I have not which
Doctor Who companions do you think could
have made a good doctor do you think the
doctors they travel with would have been
a good companion um honestly and maybe
it's partly because we were teased it
with the doctor Donna I think Donna
would have made a really cool
companion and I think tenet would have
been awesome as her sidekick
so there you go what made you want to be
a performer's and specifically do
burlesque I kind of fell into birla I
mean I want to be a performer because I
enjoy performing that's just kind of
something that I really enjoy doing and
I have
very young age I fell into burlesque
almost kind of by default because I was
trying to make it in drag in I started
in Boston and then I was in New York and
I was having trouble for various reasons
that aren't worth getting into and I
kind of accidentally stumbled across
burlesque and found a couple of things
that worked out really well one being
the nature of burlesque and how it isn't
the expectations of it naturally fit my
instincts as a performer way better than
the expectations of drag anyways and
also burlesque is like super open to new
talent and Outsiders and there's ton of
amateur shows and people are willing if
they see you perform they're willing to
take a chance on you and yeah worked out
really well I love I love the burlesque
community if you could visit any
fictional world what would it be what
would you do there like I I thought
about this but I keep ever since high
school I keep coming back to this
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy I would
I would be researching for the guy I'd
be hitching myself around bumming lifts
and and drinking as a gender-fluid
individual how does that aspect of your
identity influence if at all your poke
your approach to or view on the
thirteenth doctor I don't think that it
does maybe it might be in the back of my
head because stuff like that kind of
always is but I don't it's not part of
my active thought process because I
don't think of the doctors gender-fluid
yes the doctors changed gender but it
wasn't by choice it wasn't at least it
hasn't been displayed as depicted is
basically been depicted as oh this
regeneration is a woman okay it wasn't a
pull towards the feminine wasn't a
desire an internal need so I don't think
of the doctor as a representation of
gender fluid or transgender or anything
of that nature because that drive to
changes and isn't in there you know
internally within the character which
doctor would you most want to travel
with probably Smith because I think I
get along with him the best I intended
sake a pally but I really worry I would
get on his nerves so moving along next
thing that I received let's see
Oh before I mentioned Dave I did get
your package I meant to mention this the
last couple of live streams I had tried
to explain what it is is a little bit
weird cuz this was kind of cooling
unique but yeah I got it no I feel like
I sort of been slacking on making you
aware of that
what do we have here against me the
trans trans gender dysphoria blues I
know this wasn't on your list but this
bands music has helped me throw a lot
it's okay to say it's from me if you
mentioned the gifts at some point from
Dakota Raptor I am I'm gonna have to
check this out I am immediately curious
and that's what I mean that's really
cool that like the wish list is there as
a guide but you know people who I got a
number of things where people send me
stuff that was kind of like close to
their own hearts and that's really
awesome
when that happens what gave you the
inspiration to start doing YouTube um
initially just to kind of get a monkey
off my back cuz I'd had a I had a
concept for a well originally it was
gonna be like a half-hour sitcom you
know about geeky friends and then that
sort of turned into the shorts that this
channel originally originally was it was
a series of scripted shorts and I never
expected it to go anywhere I just kind
of like I need to do this so that it's
done and that I can move on and do other
stuff
um but after it was done I'm like I
didn't want the channel to just to sit
there and so I started doing the rambles
to camera then and then that started
coming very naturally to me and that's
just how I've been doing it since over
on the very wild channel which is
actually older than this one is that was
just wishing to get information and
stuff that I thought would be helpful
out there for other people what is your
favorite movie ghostbusters
the original Ghostbusters Age no it did
that one what are your favorite and
least favorite moments from Doctor Who
the like I I could honestly devote lists
to these but like so I mean some some
easy ones the the breaking down the wall
and Heaven Sent is is a top that's a
favorite everybody lives that's a
favorite you know from series 1 the the
doctor you know with with with River
Song screwdriver
you know Tennant saved her that's a
favorite moments that I really can't
stand out the big one being hell-bent
like almost all of it and then the Rose
encouraging the Sun to go back to his
abusive father and like talk to him and
like connect with him at the end of
idiots Lantern I completely forgot about
that till he did the rewatch and like hi
dad and the Reapers from Father's Day
because Father's Day could have been
really good but I hate those things
what was the first geeky thing you were
into probably Star Wars I was kind of
raised I don't actually don't remember
seeing Star Wars for the first time
that's how young it was well my mother
showed it to me ever consider putting up
some virile wild merch I I know I would
buy it no I haven't thought of that
because I don't know what the heck it
would be and like I'm I don't I don't
know if I have the comments to literally
just put my face on on merch I mean I
guess I kind of have cuz the cuz you can
get logo t-shirts and it's an artistic
rendering I don't know that feels
different though I'm like I'm not above
it I would but then that said there's
some gender related stuff it's actually
in the merch store for council of geeks
like there I did a shirt out of the
Nerdist constant the gender is fluid so
you know that kind of stuff is available
in the merch store on the on the
teespring merch store what would be your
ideal Dalek story and how would you take
them in a new direction I keep coming
back to the idea of a Dalek Civil War
and a Dalek doctor light episode where
the focus is on
like because we've had mention of like
Dalek concentration camps and things
like that I would love to get a Z to get
a zero in and a focus on on normal
people caught up in the middle of two
warring factions of Daleks where the
doctor shows up and only is able to save
some of the people and is not able to
stop the Daleks and what they're doing
in that in that moment that sort of
general concept what are the different
ways we can support an awesome creator
like you well I mean the patreon is the
big one
there is the merch store which I
mentioned by my book you buy my play if
you're over 18 for play you could you
know and you could honestly watching
helps and I think the big thing that
this thing is just kind of spreading the
word if I put out something that you
that worked particularly for you share
it with other people that would be a
thing that would be I think honestly
possibly the most helpful well that in
the patreon but I mean that those are
the things and and you know just
sticking around and putting up with me
that works what do you think is the
right amount of lgbtq+ representation in
a given piece of media and actually this
came with a bunch of other similar
questions like various angles of that
but I think the short answer is that
there is no formula for how to do good
representation it's always gonna be
context and specifics dependent I can't
provide you or anyone else like this
many characters get this number of lines
and they have to do this like I can't
there's no mathematical equation for
correct representation I mean a good
baseline is to try and do proportional
so you know I talked about this with
Harry Potter lgbtq+ people are roughly
4% of the population so if you've got
100 characters try and have four from be
lgbtq+ you know that but the the big
question for me is answered by
when there's enough representation that
it doesn't have to get justified anymore
so like when you no longer have to ask
me that question
that's when will you when we've got
enough when are we getting a hitchhikers
guide video towel day I've said this
before witch doctors or doctor actors
would you date I don't I don't think
there's any of the doctors I'd actually
want a date like I'd love to hang out
with them but like actually dating them
as I don't know
I mean tenants the most dashing but he
also he also turns on a dime I'm not
sure I'm up for somebody that volatile
as far as the actors I would date
Capaldi in a hot minute oh yeah what do
you consider to be the best day of your
life I'm gonna be super cheeseball and
say the day my daughter was born all
right time for another one of these oh
oh that would be the council of geeks
logo in cross stitch whoa okay that oh
boy call that one I expect it would be
an understatement
I was gonna send this over Christmas but
real life got in the way I mean hold
jeez I can imagine this this took a bit
of time a bit of work anyway I hope you
have a very happy birthday may the rest
of you be filled with love happiness and
good things all the best
oh this Oh
you people are awesome this is amazing
what is your favorite and least favorite
classic who story so far favorite
classic whose story is city of death
least favorite so far is I think I think
it's the two doctors I'm not sure that
that's actually the worst one I've seen
but it's the one that was the hardest
for me to have to watch could you please
take off the Hat sure we can do that do
you think it's better for Doctor Who to
do more single episode adventures or
more two-part stories I don't I I think
a healthy mix is good because I don't
think one is inherently better than
another I mean a good there's there's
nothing like a good two-parter but the
problem is when two barters are bad it's
that much longer you're stuck with
something that's not working so I don't
think what is inherently better than the
other and there are amazing standalone
episodes as well I mean blinks kind of
the quintessential one but I even though
it builds off of what came before and
kinda ends on a cliffhanger I still
personally consider Heaven Sent to be a
largely standalone story so you know it
and Vincent the doctor that's another
standalone what I don't think there is
an inherently more or less value with
either a single episode or two parts
story has reducing the amount of videos
you do per week is that helping the
channel or you personally ideally both
the hope is that not having to have a
video every day is gonna give me the
opportunity to not win every single
video I put out but every now and then
get more ambitious and try things that
are a little bit more intensive work for
me usually on the editing end of things
so it and it has freed me up and made me
able to do that and it is my hope that
my ability to put more time into some of
these will help the channel so far at
the very least I can say it hasn't hurt
anything I haven't I haven't had numbers
for views or subscribers or anything
else drop since stopping doing the daily
videos any more collaborations was to
bagful plan not specific ones but yeah I
would really love to to collaborate was
to again if you were to end Doctor Who
anywhere in the existing show tweaking
the episode a little to make it work
where would it be the doctor Falls I
think having the doctor die for good in
a story you know where he has that
shouting at the master just be kind you
know I do it because it it's right it I
don't do it because it works cuz it
almost never does I think that would
have been a powerful point to end on I'm
not saying the show should have ended
there I'm glad it didn't but yeah that
would have been a good that would have
been a strong end what is your deathbed
movie so this is like the last movie I'd
want to see before I die and the thing
is I thought really hard I couldn't come
up with a movie but there's a black
mirror episode San Junipero that would
be my deathbed viewing what's a show you
always want to watch but I haven't had
the time to see yet do you want the list
oh man I'll stop my head supernatural
Battlestar Galactica Avatar The Last
Airbender gravity falls Steven universe
Adventure Time like but the list goes on
and on and on and on it's it's it feels
like I'm always adding more things to
the list of shows that I would like to
see and just I never find the time what
lgbtq+ topics do you have planned for
the future or well I'm I'm the specific
ones that I've got planned right I mean
I've got a lot of likes I've got like a
list of spit ball ideas the ones that I
know are gonna happen and that I have
specifically planned out are gonna be my
own personal favorite films that include
lgbtq+ representation talking about
bisexual representation and bisexual
erasure and the barrier gays trope that
those are the next few that I am working
on I'm not gonna promise what order
those happen in but that's the plan if
you have to pay this one was fun if you
have to pick an actor who played Batman
to play the doctor who would it be also
if you had to pick an actor who played
the doctor to play Batman who would it
be so for a Batman actor to play a
doctor Adam West oh really
think about it as for a doctor acted to
play Batman
I'm gonna go slightly obscure and poss
we shouldn't count but I'm gonna do it
anyway Richard II grant if you had to be
bitten and therefore become yourself a
vampire or werewolf with all their
respective powers abilities and
weaknesses the standard ones which would
you rather become NY ah I'm inclined to
say vampire just because I don't like
the idea of such a such a loss of
control that comes with the whole
werewolf thing then again there's a
while I think there's bigger potential
to do a lot of damage in werewolf right
I think if I could just get myself
locked up and it is if it is reliably
cycled to the moon that's probably a
better way for me to not ever hurt
anybody whereas vampire I Mac I actually
am kind of required to and you know the
the workarounds in fiction like Oh will
rob the blood bank yeah it like sounds
good on paper how do you do that I don't
know how you do that so yeah I probably
werewolf which lines are phrases from
Doctor Who do you use in your daily life
um I'm not I'm not sure how much I do
like I'm not a I I kind of got out of
the habit like back around college and
slightly after I got out of the habit of
quoting things from my geeky loves
because people kept not getting it and
looking at me like I was weird so I just
kind of broke the habit that said there
is a doctor who lined that like I do try
and keep in the back of my head and I
kind of use a little bit as a guiding
principle it's from a big finished story
called the Holy Terror and the Sixth
Doctor and he says it doesn't matter
towards whom the cruelty is directed the
cruelty itself is wrong and I try very
hard to keep that one in mind favorite
superhero and super villain spider-man
mystique any guilty pleasure TV shows or
just any show yuria you like even though
you know they're bad um I mean I I don't
really do the guilty pleasure thing and
so bad it's good isn't like really my
bag I mean I will admit that
Gotham is pretty ridiculous back it
there was a point
when I used to watch Jersey Shore I
actually got paid to write about Jersey
Shore and articles that you can't find
anymore because it was it was part of
Yahoo's contributor system which they
completely disabled and and wiped all of
the all the articles you have to go to
the wayback machine to find this stuff
if he even can but yeah I I used to and
I was gonna say make a living I got paid
chump change but I did used to
professionally write about Jersey Shore
oh boy
that's a skeleton in my closet have you
ever thought about writing a book either
about Doctor Who itself or its universe
um see I'm not sure if they're asking
it's like a book about like the show and
like the philosophy of the show or
whatever which like who just requires
way more research than I feel I would
ever be equipped to do very well um or
if they're asking if I would write a
piece of fiction set in that which if
they ever commissioned me to do it I
would do in a heartbeat but for fun no
cuz if I'm gonna sink that much time to
something I want to be able to publish
it
ego okay next up from Australia I do not
envy you the postage having had to mail
some things to overseas locations it
adds up quickly see what I got here dear
Nathaniel happiest of birthdays to you I
hope you have an absolutely awesome day
get spoiled any cake ha ha I really love
your channel I think you're awesome
apologies that this isn't actually the
the envelope had a seal on it so it says
apologies that this isn't actually a
Hogwarts letter but hey it's nice
writing paper much love it's also got a
Hogwarts seal on the card which is very
cool I gotta I gotta like get a
I don't know something just to store
physical correspondence saying because
right now they're just kind of in a pile
and I really gotta I gotta get
organization in my life going on here
what do we get I see the green so I know
we got okay so we've got Slytherin pen
pencil
it's got logo and hello there's sequins
oh oh okay this that's getting worn next
Harry Potter video oh oh oh that feels
comfortable as heck - what else do we
got
hey ah Slytherin journal I've boy I've
gotten a couple of journals I got this
and they got the fairy one which I
showed at the last livestream I've got a
gonna start using journals more because
like I have been writing a lot lately
but usually I just write you know pipe
it out I need to start making use of the
notebooks more I used to be better about
it
like I because I don't want these to sit
around these are awesome of all the MCU
movies have you ever seen one that was
outright bad I don't think so the worst
they've been for me is either boring or
frustrating and I've got kind of the
trifecta for that which is Thor the dark
world Iron Man 2 and ant-man of the
walls
what country would you most like to
visit in why um like if I could if I
could go with someone I knew who spoke
the language I'd like to go to Japan
France would also be very cool but like
I I mean
classic Americans I can't I can't speak
anything besides English and and I don't
have a lot of things that set off an
anxiety but the idea of being in a
country where I can't speak the language
is bad that said some things I like I I
went to the Montreal burlesque Festival
a little over a year and a half ago and
Montreal is heavily french-speaking and
most of the people could speak English
too but it was obviously their second
language and just that threw me off
that's just Canada do you think it's
necessary to adapt a book or comic
faithfully to the big screen not only do
I not think it's necessary I think there
have been movies in recent years that
have been flat-out hurt by how slavishly
they have stuck to the original work so
I I really I honored the votive like the
Watchmen movies my my go-to example of
that but I I do think there are there
are projects that have been actively
harmed by how close they stuck to the
source material what do you think of the
Punisher movies Dolph Lundgren Thomas
Jane Ray Stevenson I actually haven't
seen the Dolph Lundgren one as of this
recording it's been on my to-do list for
ages the Thomas Jane one I it's not a
great Punisher movie but it's a pretty
good revenge movie um and I actually
really liked Punisher war zone I think
Ray Stevens is the best Punisher we've
had so far do you know your myers-briggs
type I don't like I think I knew at one
point like maybe 15 years ago but I
don't remember what are your favorite
90s comedies the last one that spoke to
you while you are a teenager probably
Dogma the thing is most nineties
comedies have aged really badly and even
at the time like in the 90s I was much
more likely to watch old Mel Brooks or
Monty Python that I was the new comedies
of the age do you watch or read
mysteries at all um sort of like not not
like as a genre but I will I like things
with mystery
elements it's a little bit I'm kind of
the same way with horror I will usually
not seek out horror stories but there's
horror elements that I do tend to enjoy
are you neurotypical um so the the
person who asked this made it clear that
that they themselves were autistic and
they basically were wondering if I had
any atypical neurological things going
on and I have a DD which is something
that I'll probably devote a video on at
some point down the line but yeah I
don't I don't have a 100% standard
functioning brain which boy people
probably could have guessed that huh who
was the first person you came out to and
how did you do it first person I came
out to basically taught me that okay
trying to think of the short version of
this story so my daughter's mother we
dated in college and at that point I had
not come out to anybody I didn't really
have an understanding of myself as
gender-fluid at that point it was just
identifying as a crossdresser and she I
went to work I think cuz I was I was
shelving books at Barnes & Noble in the
morning and I came back and she was she
had hung out in my dorm waiting for me
to come back and I came back and she had
found a pair of pantyhose and kind of
confronted me with them and said whose
are these thinking they were another
woman's and realizing she was already
mad at me figured I had nothing to lose
I kind of shrugged and went those are
mine and she kind of looked at them
looked at me and went oh well that's
okay then so that was the first person I
came out to I do enjoy sharing that
story you've published an advice book
and a play and you've mentioned working
on novels is there a literary form you
prefer working in I'm probably most that
he's working in either stage play or
screenplay format just because you know
writing you know working on novels which
which I am still doing the the stuff
that's hardest for me is describing
things
it's like dialog comes very natural to
me and bullet pointing this than this
than this
and then just sort of presenting it and
leaving it to a director to decide
exactly how that's gonna look that that
just flows better for me were you aware
you had a group of fans in France I was
not haha it's it's a bit funny to me
where some of you folks are located it's
very cool out of on a scale of one being
Hartnell ten being Tennant how would you
rank the Doctor Who TV movie I Boy
well they clarified that John Hurt
counts as a half so I guess I would rank
it as a Davison and a hurt you seem to
have a considerable amount of art in
your home do you have a favorite artist
yes my favorite artist is yoshitaka
amano who is best known for doing the
conceptual and promotional art for the
final fantasy series he has this
wonderful serial quality to his art that
I just really find hypnotic do you
prefer Apple or Android I have never
used an Android device I stick to Apple
cuz it's what I started on and I like to
stick to what I know I was wondering
what your thoughts on the conjuring
movies are um I've only seen the first
conjuring and I liked it well enough I
didn't I didn't like how over the top of
the finale god I wish the finale had
been grounded enough that I could have
believed it actually happened because up
until the the climax of the thing it had
kept things pretty grounded in a way
that I I would have been inclined to go
you know maybe that did happen but then
the climax went it overreached and and
kind of broke the spell for me a little
bit and so I haven't seen the other ones
I mean it's good for what it is but I
didn't get sucked in you have a lot of
irons in the fire writing dancing
modeling you to be etc if you had to
restrict yourself to one creative outlet
what would it be and why
I suppose if I could only do one it
would stick to YouTube because it would
allow me to still dabble in others I you
know maybe I wouldn't get to perform on
a stage but I could still like shoot a
video of a performance number and upload
it I could write you know sketches and
put those together so YouTube is a broad
enough medium that it could allow me to
dabble in other stuff but boy I really
do need to keep my to keep my fingers on
a lot of pies old were you when you
discovered your sense of a gender-fluid
self I honestly don't know how to answer
that I started like intentionally
cross-dressing like around 10 or 11 I
say that because like growing up the
neighbors had daughters and we used to
play dress-up with their stuff because
they were older than me so I could fit
in their stuff and I would be put into
twos and whatever else and I thought
nothing of it so consciously
cross-dressing was about 10 or 11 sort
of coming to enough of one of an
understanding to realize that I wasn't I
didn't have a desire to transition to a
full-time life as a woman that came in
my early 20s feeling comfortable with
actually calling myself gender fluid as
a as a label that came in my early
thirties so it's been a journey and it
will probably continue to evolve if you
can bring back three one-off companions
from the modern era of Doctor Who who
would you choose Jackson Lake the
engineer from mummy on the Orient
Express I do not remember his name and I
had Oh
Victorian governess version of Clara is
there any creative form you'd like to be
good at but aren't yeah I'd love to be
able to play an instrument and I just
don't have the patience or the
discipline to ever get good at it if we
got another female master do you think
she should be called miss again or
something else like the mistress or just
simply called the master I definitely
don't think if we get another female
master again that she should be called
Missy I feel like Missy was very
specific to Michelle Gomez's
interpretation of the character that
said if we have a if the master comes
back and is a woman again I would like
her to just be called the master because
as much as I love Missy
when that moment happened of her being
like well you know short for mistress I
couldn't very well call myself the
master could I I remember thinking why
not go for it come on this is an
interesting one curious where this is
going
wrist measurements for wrist cuffs and
neck measurements for choker or neck
cuff okay well let's find out
wrist wrist looks to be about seven and
a half inches and neck so that's
touching but they're about sixteen
sixteen sixteen and a half really
curious where that's going what's a
piece of media you watched with your
daughter that you expected to only
entertain to her but where you also wand
up enjoying it actually the trolls booby
I was surprised how much I enjoyed that
I love the the sort of fuzzy felt
aesthetic to it I liked how sort of
weirdly cruel the world it takes place
in and I like I like some of the songs
so yeah I did that to be painful for me
it's not like a great film but no I
liked it pretty well what is your
favorite food homemade macaroni and
cheese you said you're a dog person do
you have a favorite breed nostalgically
it's gotta be the dachshunds or bulldogs
cuz I've had both and loved both if you
compare any two people up with each
other in the MCU and a hero sidekick
kind of way what do you think would be a
fun pair I think you have a Spidey and
Doctor Strange which is a fun pairing in
the comics when it happens and Valkyrie
and whatever the heck kat dennings his
character's name was last thing that
i've got today and like i said more
stuff may or may not be at later times
and that stuff will probably get
mentioned on live streams so
Oh Nick good man
and I don't feel bad mentioning his name
cuz I kissed his name has come up a few
times and and deservedly so and he was
an extra on Doctor Who once makes a good
guy birthday greetings from the bar side
thanks for the great work happy birthday
best best wishes mr. adipose because
that was the episode he was in I met God
it's been a while since I mentioned this
if you if you watch partners in crime
they when there's like all these
cutaways of people like starting to blow
oh because the adipose is activating
there's a guy like standing at a bar
who's kind of like oh that's Nick which
makes me very happy
okay so yes we have we have Christmas
patterns which again I ain't gonna judge
if it's what you got that's totally fine
by me okay so we have Batman femme
fatales we have Batgirl
we've got Harley Quinn and we've got
poison ivy oh man I gotta rearrange the
shelf
these are good problems to have so oh
man a couple more questions then we'll
wrap this one up oh nice do you think
one in done comics issues I can still be
sold and marketed properly I don't know
if they can I feel like the death of the
the drugstore spinarak was kind of the
fact that those don't exist anymore
makes one-and-done
storytelling just not not as sustainable
as it was anymore or as appealing
because that was the market that those
were good for in that market doesn't
exist now what are some of your favorite
video games um
Final Fantasy 6 uh Secret of Mana
journey try the Final Fantasy Tactics
Super Metroid those those are some of
the big ones of tell me there's a lot
that I like Tetris attack mm-hmm are you
planning to attend any comic-con panel
this year anywhere I'm I'm probably
gonna go to terrific on in Connecticut I
haven't locked that down 100% yet but
that's looking pretty strong at this
point I'm in school and get crap loads
of homework any tips on how to keep a
consistent schedule no I'm actually
really bad at it I I'm not a good
planner and I honestly don't know how
I've been able to keep this up
consistently you don't want tips for me
I don't have them so that's gonna wrap
this up folks you were awesome you know
with stuff and questions and watching
and listening and being the council
there's all the links there's stuff I'm
sure I'm gonna have a great birthday
obviously I'm recording this slightly in
advance of that but I'm feeling good
right now and you folks are a big part
of that so thanks a lot all the links
down below usual stuff you know the
spiel and the reason you know it is
because you're the council I just run
the meetings and until next time this
council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]